congressional testimony by Trump's
former lawyer Michael Cohen every that's
been on TV all day long it's yeah I got
up this morning it was on I was watching
it with my kids yeah you're like Daddy
what's hush money I was like I'll pay
you $20 if you'd never ask that again it
was really interesting there was some
riveting moments yeah to the testimony
today Michael Cohen called President
Trump a con man and a racist yeah
Trump passed yeah but did he say
anything bad about me good to the bad
stuff we all know what we know why do
you think my base loves me I know at the
very end of the hearing at the very end
of the hearing Michael Cohen Cohen said
he hopes his testimony heals America
that's what he said
yeah not only is Michael Cohen a bad
lawyer he's a terrible doctor all that
was interesting Cohen said this this was
fascinating to me he said that President
Trump has gone to great lengths to keep
his SAT scores secret he's President of
the United States his scores must be
really bad yeah they must be really
really bad if he's pressed he's like no
one can ever know I may never get a job
I copy must be terrible no wonder Trump
created his own University
seriously I sleep like that his own
University hey my got into trouble you I
find me ma